- That's when I was like, "You know what?
"Maybe you're gay."
And little did I realize I am very gay.
- We had an email at Buzzfeed asking us
if there were any moments that
really defined our sexuality.
Or, like, kind of made us
realize who we were inside.
And, I hadn't really given it any thought.
And then it (laughs) came to me.
That scene where that very hot, tan,
almost like Grecian, European looking guy.
I can't remember whether
he reaches for his phone
or if he reaches over, but he like...
He reaches.
I remember literally pausing it
on the button on the DVD
and being like (gasps).
Okay, play!
And that was it.
It was like a brief little
moment I had with myself.
And I didn't touch myself
or anything like that.
But it was like, "Hm,
"that was nice."
- You know that scene in Mulan
where she chops off all her hair
and becomes a badass member
of the (laughs) army.
And just, like, defies
so many gender roles.
That really did it for me.
Realizing that I was attracted
to something so fluid
kind of scared me, but
also it was super exciting.
I was just shown something
that I hadn't ever seen before.
Thank you Mulan (laughs)
for helping this gay
baby heart find herself.
- I think when I was six or seven,
I was watching a Ricky Martin
concert on TV with my family.
I distinctly remember him
singing Livin' La Vida Loca,
his shirt was not on and
I remember being like,
"Oh, okay."
I still love Ricky Martin.
It was actually a pretty cool moment
for me when he came out.
This is somebody that I grew
up admiring, I love his music.
Seeing kind of your childhood icon,
like, identify the same way that you do.
- One of my pop culture moments
was when I was watching
K.Will's Please Don't.
It is a Korean pop music video.
And it has like a huge plot
twist that I was not ready for.
It seems like the director was shooting
as if the guy was jealous of the girl.
Crazy thing is, the guy actually
is falling for the groom.
And it was, like, mind blowing!
I was like, "Whoa, so
all this time he's gay?"
As a person of color, as a
person that's from Asian descent,
this is a topic that we
don't really approach
and we don't talk about.
There's not much
representation in these roles.
So, to see someone that looked like me,
that has similar skin color as me
and has same facial structure as me,
that helped me, in terms
of who I think gay is,
what gay means, to who I am.
- So, my gay awakening
occurred when I was watching
Brokeback Mountain with my parents.
This fairly explicit gay sex scene
was just, like, kind of happening.
I was like, "Oh, what's going on here?"
Seeing an example of gay intimacy
on screen and realizing
that that was something
I was curious and fascinated
by and interested in.
Was, like, immediately
paired with a moment
of my parents telling me that
what I had just started to see was bad.
They made me leave the room.
And, for the record, my parents let me
watch straight sex scenes.
So, it wasn't just that
it was a sex scene.
It's that it was a gay sex scene.
I think before watching the
sex scene in Brokeback Mountain
I did know that I was gay,
but it wasn't something
that I was cognizant of.
It was something that was
definitely a little repressed.
Watching that scene helped
me realize something
that I already knew, but was
afraid to admit to myself.
- There's not really that many,
like, lesbian iconic moments
that made me realize, like,
this is also, too, how I feel.
Any time there was, like,
a strong female lead
on whatever I was watching, I
would just be like obsessed.
And be like, "Oh my god, I love her.
"Not in a gay way.
"But also in a gay way, probably."
I'm pretty sure baby me
had a huge crush on Carmen from Spy Kids.
Girl was resourceful, so intense
and so just, like, true to who she is.
But, at the end of the
day, is just like a softy
and, like, just wants to take care of Juni
and his weird wart fingers.
And like, I don't know,
I think she's a really cool character.
It's so weird to, like,
look back and be like,
"Those are such gay things
going through your head."